-We are here with
James Beard Award-winning chef
Rick Martínez,
whose book -- whose cookbook,
"Mi Cocina: Recipes and Rapture
From My Kitchen in Mexico,"
is available now.
Rick, what are we
going to make today?
Thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
Well, it's the holidays.
-Yes.
-So we have to make tamales.
-Great.
-But first we have a cocktail.
-This is the cocktail here.
-This is the cocktail, yes.
-Oh, it's very warm.
It has a warm feeling to it.
-Yes, I know.
So, I'm going to let you
pour the tequila.
-Oh, there's --
Tequila goes in this.
-Yes.
-Is this...
This isn't now mulled wine,
is it, right?
-No, this --
this is a hibiscus hot toddy.
-Oh! I'm very excited.
-So we've got some
cinnamon, peppercorn, clove,
and then, obviously tequila.
-Alright. Thank you.
Here we go. Cheers.
Happy holidays, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, this is wonderful.
I've had tamales before.
I've never had a brown butter
pecan tamale.
Is this like a dessert --
a dessert tamale?
-It is a complete dessert.
I'm going to switch places.
-Okay. Great.
-Real quick.
Um, so, yeah, I love tamales.
And not a lot of Americans
or Mexicans actually know
that you can make sweet tamales.
And this is kind of inspired
by my love of
butter pecan ice cream.
-Okay, great.
-So toasted pecans, brown
butter, and masa.
-Alright. Great. And so how do
you go about it here?
-Okay.
So I'm going to have you stir.
-Stir? Okay. Great.
-This is the masa harina
and the toasted pecans.
And we have very --
-I'm doing very good so far.
-Yes, we have half and half.
-Okay.
-And sweetened condensed milk.
-Great.
-Some vanilla.
We're gonna, like, play up those
kind of ice creamy flavors.
And then to play up
the toasted nuts,
we've got some brown butter
because also I
love brown butter.
-Alright.
This is very good, very light.
-Yeah, doesn't it seem light?
-It does seem light.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It does. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay. So, yeah, really, really,
really get in there.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But I could really,
really do this,
but I can also
tell someone already has,
so why don't we skip
to that part?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
who are we doing here, right?
It's not CGI.
They all can see it.
-Okay. So, now
we're going to roll them up.
So I'll do one for you.
Grab grab a...
-Alright. Great.
And while we roll,
I want to ask about the book
because one of
the things you did,
I think the biggest mistake
anybody could make is saying,
"Oh, Mexican food
is one thing."
You went to all
the different regions and --
and was that
a fun journey for you?
Did you know it all,
or did you learn stuff?
-No. I grew up in Texas,
and I grew up
thinking that --
-Whoo!
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Chuckles ] Hook 'em.
-Yeah.
-So I grew up thinking
that we ate Mexican food,
you know, like, and really,
it was Tex-Mex and, um...
Sorry. Okay.
-No, no. This is --
What I'm doing is good.
-Yeah, yeah. And then just --
[ Laughs ]
It's perfect. It's beautiful.
Exactly.
-Oh, my God. Look at that.
[ Stammering ]
-There you go.
Um, I grew up thinking that
we ate Mexican food, and so I...
When I started
traveling in Mexico,
I was like, "This is nothing
like what we ate."
-Right.
-And so I just wanted
to explore, and so I bought
a car in Mexico City
and literally drove
about 30,000 miles
exploring the entire country,
every state.
-That's amazing.
-Yeah. Eating my way around.
-And now tell me, there's a --
I think a lot of times
people use
the word authentic, uh,
to refer to foods
from different countries.
You do not care
for the word authentic.
-I actually hate that word,
because I feel like,
like in this country,
Mexican cooks
cook with what they love,
with what they have,
with what's in season.
And so here we talk about
authentic as being like,
this is the one way
that you make tamales.
And so I started exploring
the country of Mexico
and thinking I'm going to find
that one version of pozole,
that one version
of the tamale,
and actually, no,
everybody just cooks for fun.
It's their creative outlet.
If you invite 10 people
over to your house
and you ask them
to make the same dish,
you're going to have 10
amazingly different
versions of it.
And so I feel like, you know,
we shouldn't -- we don't
need that word.
-Yeah. Give yourself
the freedom to explore outside
of whatever authentic is.
Alright.
Now show me what we do here.
-Okay.
-Very excited.
-So this is actually
my favorite moment.
This is the moment when you've
been waiting for 45 minutes.
We've steamed these tamales
and now we have the reveal.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Yes.
-Oh. Yes.
-Oh, they really smell good.
Alright.
-Yeah, yeah. So -- But...
-They're so hot.
-I actually have...
-Why did I stick
my hand in there?
-Because it's fun.
-Okay, great. Oh, see?
-For you.
-That's when you got to go,
"Stop, stop,
we made it already."
-Exactly.
-Okay, great.
-And to gild the lily
a little bit,
I added some dulce de leche
and some extra toasted pecans.
-This looks fantastic.
I'm very excited, Rick.
-Alright. Cheers.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, well. Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-Mmm!
This is amazing, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up
for Chef Rick Martínez!
"Mi Cocina: Recipes and Rapture
From My Kitchen in Mexico"
is available now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."